hello so I haven't participated in the
project for awesome in about four years
that's embarassing sorry but I felt
compelled this year to add to the piles
of worthy causes that people are gonna
be talking about across YouTube today
because I have finally found a charity
that I really care about I do have to
warn you though there is potential for
things to get a little bit sad today
because this is a pretty serious topic
but I will endeavor to keep it as light
as I can you already know what my
charity is could send the title but I'll
say anyway
my charity for this year's project for
awesome is the out Simon Society so
facts about Alzheimer's disease it's the
most common cause of dementia it mainly
affects people over the age of 65 simply
put what it does is progressively kill
off brain cells and it's rubbish it's
really not nice I don't like it symptoms
of it include memory loss confusion
problems with speech and understanding
and ultimately death because the worst
thing about Alzheimer's is there is
currently no known treatment for it so
just like a lot of other people who have
a strong allegiance to a particular
charity Alzheimer's is something that
has affected me personally my granddad
Joe who I happen to be named after my
middle name is Joseph had Alzheimer's
and unfortunately he passed away couple
years ago now now not gonna lie and say
that me and my granddad were inseparably
close he did live quite far away so I
didn't see him all that often but he was
a lovely person and he was definitely a
friend to me when I was younger and so
seeing him go through what he did was
hard for me and that's just that's just
me I can't even imagine what it must
have been like for him the whole thing
happened pretty slowly it's not I'd
would just sort of like missing names
and dates and things but eventually
whole people would just like disappear
from his head and I would go to see I
mean he just wouldn't know who I was
anymore and I sort of wouldn't know who
he was anymore even because he was
although it was still clearly a person
he just wasn't the same person that I
felt like I used to know regrettably for
me it was only after Joe had passed away
that I discovered the outside of society
and started learning about the great
work they do helping to fund research
looking for a cure for the disease but
also providing vital information about
what the disease actually is and helping
people who have the disease to have a
better quality of life
if you'd like to know more about the
charity they actually have a pretty
decent YouTube channel where they have
information about the science behind
dementia but also some really great
humanizing stories about people who live
with
one of the videos that really struck me
personally was about this woman called
Linda basically what she did is she
joined a choir for dementia sufferers
funded by the outsider society even
though she had no interest in seeing it
never really had sung in her life what
she got out of it was being able to
spend time with people who really
understood what she was going through
and what she said was that she was just
happy to be around people who would
allow her to finish her sentence instead
of having other people try and finish
her sentence for her and that just
really made me think back to my
experience with Jo because that is the
urge I had I wanted to finish the
sentences I wanted him to be on the same
mental level as me when he just wasn't
and I didn't understand that and so it
made things uncomfortable and I just
didn't really want to spend time with
him anymore because I didn't understand
it and if I had had that understanding I
would have spent more time with him and
something I just really regret I really
wished that I had known to go to the
outside in society to get the
information that I needed to understand
what was really happening to my granddad
but I didn't get that and so the best
that I can do is tell you about it in
the hopes that if you ever find yourself
in a similar situation or find a friend
in the similar situation that you know
where to go and that you can have the
information that I wish that I could
have had at the time now undoubtably
you're gonna be overwhelmed today with
many videos for great charities that you
could donate to so I'm going to try and
make things a bit easier for you I'm
setting up a just giving page for the
Alzheimer's Society and any donation
that you choose to make to that Just
Giving page I will match it up to the
value of five thousand pounds which is a
lot of money but I'm going to do it
because I think the charity is great so
hopefully you aren't for helping out
thank you happy project for awesome and
good bye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
pathetic crap that was you know I really
don't like and the screens with so many
links that you're overwhelmed with
choice I have no idea what to click on
sorry just had lots of things we wanted
to show you today I'm just gonna go
goodbye